some predictions about the virus and the
the way the sort of what's happening to
businesses right now you know on one
hand you said your timing was was good
in the sense that you've raised your big
fund before all this and now a bunch of
businesses are gonna need liquidity
they're gonna need you know somebody
who's a stable capital partner to come
in and buy them what do you guys think
what's your prediction on how this gonna
play out well for you and for the
economy I would say yeah well so so for
let me believe broader I think what what
we're predicting and of course no one
has any idea right we're I'm trying to
be best we can triangulate information
we think it's gonna be pretty long if
you want to think about it a good
analogy I heard was a blizzard a winter
or an ice age right it's kind of about
the three stages probably you know I
think the blizzards gonna last for
another at least six to eight weeks
probably longer than that
and then I think we're going through a
period of it's be hard to restart a lot
of these businesses so there's in in
theory it sounds oh there's economic
problems it's no big deal you just kind
of go into hibernation and come back out
of it and everything's fine right in
practice there's a lot of start/stop
problems I mean you guys have run
businesses you know if you had to
mothball everything and try to restart
it I mean you're not be able to do it at
least be very difficult to do it and so
my guess is there's me a lot of pain and
suffering
so in our portfolio you know because we
don't use debt and we have good balance
sheets and obviously we have a financial
firm to back it up
you know Ward me fine I mean a lot of
the businesses were involved in have
been doing better than we expected
probably two weeks ago with that said
you have no idea where demands gonna go
and I mean we're racing and we have
plans for you know depending on what
level of pain and suffering you know
happens well you know what the plan is
and you know we're gonna try to get the
things back up and running as fast as we
possibly can you know the government
intervention that just came out is
interesting and how its structured so
the Care Act just got passed around
20-30 minutes ago and you know it is
it's better than nothing it's going
through the SBA and the SBA is
to be generous like the DMV of the
finance world and so it's not going to
be an easy thing to get all that money
deployed also the the SBA lenders that
we're talking to that are at these banks
and we're not using the SBA but
obviously if it's forgivable loans then
be insane for us not to participate in
that and they don't even know what the
rules are right and so they're trying to
get triangulated on what things are so I
think there's can get a lot of confusion
I think it's gonna take a lot of time to
get the the money into people's hands
I'm not sure it's gonna actually stem
the tide as much as they think it will
on unemployment and so I fear that
unemployment could go to 2025 maybe even
30 percent which is do you think that's
realistic yeah yeah fuckin'-a man that's
crazy
yeah the put perspective but to put that
in perspective the great the the Great
Depression was what eight eighteen or
twenty I think it touched high 20s so so
I mean it's a peak and like I said I
mean I look I hope I'm wrong right let's
just say what it is I mean I hope that
that's on but this is not a good
environment for us actually I mean this
isn't interesting we could talk about as
being a you know a firm that has a lot
of cash right now
I don't think this is a good environment
for us at all I would much prefer a 2008
which is much more shallow downturn
recession this the violence of this is
basically rendering all information
available like a non-issue you just
can't there's nothing predictive about
what's happened in the past and what how
it goes in the future and demand curves
I mean we don't know no snow knows what
the demand curve looks what are you
betting for a 20% or 30% unemployment
rate well I'm not betting on it that's
why I think's gonna happen but I think
they do you think that's gonna happen I
think I think we'll probably touch 20% I
think we could touch 30% yeah and I
think we'll see it in the next six weeks
will be will be when it really comes
down my guess and I call jobs the the
jobs number the unemployment number that
came out I had said previously I thought
it was gonna be about three point five
and it being about three point three
which was wildly higher than what the
sort of consensus was a million and it
look if you're involved in small
businesses and you said there was
million people that finally found
employment
so that's a good joke of course it was
me way higher than that there's no it
couldn't be way higher than that I mean
what we're seeing is I mean I had a
buddy this week who laid off four
thousand five thousand employees this
week had another friend who laid off
five hundred and eighty five of six
hundred I mean and this is that's just
me I mean what I know they in the hotel
industry or was it just that yeah food
services one and construction was the
other so it's just it's it's it's a
tough I mean they're why do you say this
is this is not a good time versus 2008
what what is the core difference there
yeah so the the core difference is the
violence at which this had has has down
termed is is basically you could see in
2008 a nice trend right line like you
can see it's kind of like a soft hitting
private businesses right I'm not gonna
talk about stock market stock market and
private businesses you're totally
different right but in in the stock
market it was sure I had a violence to
it and then you know kind of petered out
and another violence to it this happened
it in [__] eight days right right I
mean loves you Lehman and all that stuff
compression oh I'm talking about right
now oh we have right now that's what I'm
saying is right now in in private
businesses it is worse in private
businesses than its reflected in the
stock market right now right it's hard
to know what's priced in and and what do
you do with monetary policy when you're
basically an unlimited bid i I don't
know right but I mean when you look at
it from the businesses that we interact
with it's carnage everywhere
I mean you maybe have I was saying 90%
of businesses have been adversely
affected five percent are probably you
know sort of unaffected and then maybe
five percent have some sort of tailwind
that's weird because of this but ninety
percent are just it is suffering I mean
I is unbelievable what's happening
[Music]
you